welcome everybody to the h3 podcast live
today our episode is sponsored by quip
and Dollar Shave Club more about that
later
I'm here with ela Cline what up teams
what up big boobs and incidentally this
episode is also sponsored by a liner
check out this [ __ ] check this [ __ ] out
boy are you anemic liner for life let
the world know this is what London
company would write about it
are you a you look liner for life let
the world know by heading on out to
represent calm / h3h3 let them know that
you're a [ __ ] wild and free-spirited
like ela Klein oh thank gosh like off
off the off the podcast here before we
went live how I feel like I'm becoming
like a meme I'm becoming a victim to
Poe's law do you want to explain what
pose lies so Poe's law is this like
theory that when you're making fun of
something and you get to the point where
you're indistinguishable from what
you're making fun of then you're then
there's no difference then you're just
that thing and I think that's happening
to us because if at first it was like
what up Jake Pollard's let's make fun of
that by calling it ela Kleiner's but now
we're all saying ela kleiner is not
ironic at all and now we're actually
selling merch that says what up he'll
decliners you look kleiner for life it's
still ironic I'm getting are getting
closer to not being ironic like I'm a
legit ela kleiner and you can pick up
the merch today how to represent calm /
h2 h3 but you see what I'm saying and
see what you're saying I like the long I
like though how I give the name of it
and therefore I mean for all those
raises up I'm in um I feel like that
happens a lot on the Internet where you
become victim of your yeah my first
understanding of it was with keemstar
because of his intro and we're like we
were actually wondering like what
happened the made in good this intro
like he's having a stroke every night on
camera so I my the only explanation was
it must have started as a joke but then
it actually became the thing right and
now we affirm that with them now we are
like that we like I used to say in the
comments on YouTube
god bless and I just thought that was
such a funny way to sign off a comic god
bless it's like what so then I started
written writing that and all my comments
on YouTube it's responding people and
then I started seeing people being like
is Ethan religious yeah so that's the
point it's like the parity is not that
obvious so I'm just a religious guy
saying god bless ya like I feel like I'm
becoming the me Mary more and more but
you know what you have to embrace the
meme and that's the point I think that's
what Poe's law was all about embraced
the me become the mean what up EULA
Kleiner's today we have a jam-packed
episode for you guys in honor of the net
neutrality day of awareness that was I
think yesterday anyone are they now I'm
Wednesday we put together a really great
I hope comprehensive episode about net
neutrality what is it what's at stake
Windows 10 I don't want to update I'm
about to go on a tangent I'm going to
salmon I'm controlling my day ok stay
focused what is it what's that mistake
who are the people who stand to gain
from it and you know is there any
arguments against net neutrality I hope
to answer all those questions as best as
I can as interesting as possible but
first we have the news speaking of which
we're trying to step up a little bit the
format my dream for the show is to turn
it into a whole mishmash multimedia
nightmare by nightmare I meet something
pleasure but for example today we have a
full segment of news stories awesome
real some offbeat
and I want to try doing this every week
if you guys enjoy it where we go over
some some current events and then we get
into the either the interview or the
segment the main segment and take it
from there so if that if that sounds
good or not you don't really have a
choice this isn't that interactive guys
I'm gonna do it regardless but highest I
set my coffee
it's an experimental show right now this
is very experimental this coffee is
really strong I feel like I'm drinking
acid the main oxygen
I've been Oh far is sake all right let's
get started now recently on our most
recent video about the new humungous
footage revealed I had encountered
something I have never seen before on
YouTube and I think anyone who saw that
video or visited the comments must have
seen it as well
it was absolute [ __ ] bananas let me
pull the [ __ ] up if you spend even one
seconds time in there you would have
seen this I'm gonna need some help we
can network here look at this yeah this
is 15 top comments are all spam bots all
of them I've never seen anything like
this how do I move this what is this
okay here you go can you show it done
can you see it all right dad go we have
reached our goal of subscribers here's a
special gift for you and a link one two
three and all the responses are spam
bots 2 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 the 16 top [ __ ] comments are
all spam bots hurry up your goodies are
waiting gift for my subscribers so what
I was wondering is like how is this even
effective at this point I have no idea
I'm so insane do you think that they
would learn a little subtlety at this
point this thing has been going on for
at least a year maybe two years yeah
it's always been there but I've never
it's always like 1 or 2 but all of a
sudden these spammers just turned into
trolls and like this isn't effective I'm
just going to ruin the YouTube comments
but my favorite part about it is when we
made a video about it
Ethan was trying to become one of the
spam bots right and you spend a bunch of
links on everyone's Channel Jeff
Dunham's website yeah not like weird
short URLs
it was literally Jeff Dunham calm and in
response to that you too actually
and they actually banned us and we
couldn't access our channel for a day
you so [ __ ] bad I love that this can
happen for two years but when you make a
parody of it we get there you get banned
like sorry we got to drop the ax on you
Ethan in ela these [ __ ] guys this top
comment right now two minutes ago
it has 1500 up votes how is it possible
for YouTube of all the big chat big
companies in the world owned by Google
ai machine-learning top comment two
minutes
second one three minutes these are all
posted very recently and have over
thousands of points it's so unnatural
and they're all named a tradition
productions how is it possible that
you're not catching this [ __ ] look at
this the crazy part is that there must
be like a couple people actually believe
it well I think that it sighs that's
definitely true but they've stepped up
their game they have fake verified
badges yeah because that was that was
YouTube's way of being like hey this is
the legit Channel so look at these
[ __ ] guys with their fake I think the
real ones blue so they found a green but
still it and also the real one will be
next to your name so they did it like
right right right you know but it's
about it but at first look for someone
who doesn't know it looks real
absolutely look at the stuff they write
is so dumb surprises for you fans take
away their take it I have a small
surprise go to but here so we're always
like who just I haven't seen one person
who buys into this stuff but I did see
one and I had to I had to save it this
guy says please stop posting all these
[ __ ] comments on your own video the
guy goes someone under he isn't it spots
hey I love that in this guy's mind
somehow I'm just spamming 15 times yeah
I would get banned if I did that anyway
if you guys stay tuned I have a gift for
all my subscribers I don't have a small
surprise for you guys check the link in
the description for that Condor you tick
what is this oh yeah this is a video I
took
have a journey into God I don't know
what's what desktop software but it is
so bad like I'm not very qualified pixel
that yeah anyway enjoy this journey 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
18
I count and that is kind of it so
hopefully what I did is I banned del use
the same link here and it's like dot t--
o-- or some [ __ ] so i banned dot t-- o--
so i'm going to see if these guys are
learning I'm gonna I'm gonna play a
little game with them whatever they're
watching right now and now they know
let's go the game is on YouTube can't
handle it so now it's time to dance and
make these spammers on dot t-- o-- but
something i've seen that they do is
they'll say like hey have a gift for you
type into Google X Y Z eleven twelve
thirteen gibberish that only goes to
their spam site yeah so they have they
have warfare these spam bothers are so
advanced it's crazy yeah that I'm afraid
for the cyber security of the world I'm
telling you these guys are inside
nuclear submarines right now it's true
like if they got this share what else
are they war town they're brilliant and
and then sometimes they'll even
impersonate the channel they'll throw
them like oh yeah yeah I used to happen
cuz yeah they're crazy man so that's our
top story watch out for the spam box
guys I mean clear I don't think I need
to tell anyone here that that's not me
that any time you see someone talking
like a 4.1 person just to that one guy
out there the next time you see what
seems to be an illiterate Chinese person
with a very spammy link it's not me okay
next up you want to take the lead on
this one yella what is it EP dudes
leader viruses click the lead you okay
this guy is a youtuber everyone loves
them on YouTube
leafyishere exam so he got his phone
hacked or whatever Mike Biggs I'm sort
of hacking happened it was snapchat Oh
snapchat yeah and so they got his nudes
and it's all over Twitter now so close
your eyes when you're on Twitter or not
or not or open a lot but watch out watch
out
so leafy his snapchat got hacked and for
some reason I mean this seems a little
bit silly to me to keep nudes on a
snapchat when you know that you're like
a high target 400 unless he wants his
dick out there which is you know god
bless you maybe he faked the hacking and
you just wanted to show people as dick
I'm also a I was I'd probably say this
time you have a new son for his dick
this channel down on the rope slightly
everybody knows that what better way to
bring it back but like I was thinking
I've never heard of a youtubers nudes
being leaked yeah and not once and you
never hear almost even if guys nudes
beam like it's always like females who
are targeted yeah can we talk about that
yeah let's talk about it what's up with
that all right we talked about I don't
know I feel bad for him on one hand I do
I definitely do
I wouldn't you know it's it's a horrible
feeling we you know we have been attempt
though have been attempt to hack into
our stuff and it was really scary yeah
I'm not not a fun experience at all no
it's horrible so you feel so vulnerable
yeah and well there's nothing more
vulnerable than severe dick out on the
Internet but again it's like dude I mean
I heat I feel like he has to take half
the blame there he had a dick pic saved
on his snapchat that is pretty strange
it's kind of a strange thing Mike I
don't use snapchat oh so I'm not sure
how weird is that
they'll have will use it's okay you
you're like what was on his phone what
man was it honest what it means if
somebody logs in your snapchat they get
access to your dick yeah straight access
like me if I'm if I'm a celebrity here's
my here's the good thing about being me
nobody wants to see me naked
all right my big pics are completely
clear but if anybody did want to see me
naked
and I was concerned about that I
wouldn't keep any nudes man if you ever
saw if you want to snap a picture of
your dick send it here erase it to the
end other photo minute yeah I mean yeah
if you want to be dangerous then but
then there's a chance that this would
happen - yeah interesting I haven't seen
him comment about it but just the fact
that leafy of all the lectures day hey
guys my dicks out there but it's
actually it's everywhere like anytime
I'm on Twitter I'm seeing leafy's dick I
learned on that same day like I was just
looking at completely unrelated to it
and it popped up it popped up literally
well we'd be next door and ears
I tell you something more to be said
about that but how much can you talk
about leafies dick I'm going to talk
about in a while so it's kind of a good
way to come in right oh man yeah that's
embarrassing if you like the older I get
the smaller my dick gets alright I get
fatter my dick gets smaller so [ __ ] up
you know what I mean like yeah you don't
have to call me I'm just talking like
you know proverbial I was hoping that
this would be like a segment of news is
this not a current event I'm trying you
know what I'm saying it's like you lose
hair on your head your dick gets sucked
into your fat your Don you've ever heard
well you know proverbial in the
proverbial sense and you grow hair on
your ass I don't understand that you
lose hair where you want it you grow
hair where you don't on your ears and
your ass your ass crap [ __ ] is that
it's like it's already hard enough to
get a date past 20 why are you doing
this to me life biologically it doesn't
even make sense
I'm evolved to [ __ ] right that's why you
exist why you putting here on my ears in
my ass and shrinking my dick that's all
I'm saying
can I get away Oh luckily I'm gonna get
an egg news story for you let's move it
on next stories a little bit serious a
little bit interesting I've been I've
been following this the Trump Russian
story because I found it really
fascinating try to be bipartisan as much
as possible because I know we have a lot
of fans who support Trump a lot of
people who don't I personally just for
transparency did not vote for Trump but
I try to give everyone a fair shake on
things this Trump Russia thing is kept
as fascinating to me because it's if it
all is proven true to me it's just so
crazy that like one side of the
political system was colluding with with
a with pretty much an amine I don't
enemy who stays maybe a little harsh but
definitely an adversary you know a
competiting country competing country
and so you guys probably followed this
story with a beef support Trump just
hear me out just listen I'm gonna lay it
out it's fascinating you should want to
hear this more than anybody okay let's
start from here so the story had come
out that Trump jr. had been talking to -
a Russian some kind of Russian
ambassador about getting information
about Clinton and and it just so
happened that Trump jr. and an attempt
to defend himself or I guess be
transparent posted on Twitter a picture
of his email correspondence with these
Russian dudes and any he pretty much
admits to some really crazy [ __ ] and he
just tweeted it out which is fascinating
let me read some of this stuff so this
guy he says hi Don that's Donald Jr but
when you're free to talk with MN by
phone about this Hillary info MN I
presume is some kind of Russian diplomat
you had mentioned earlier this week so
wanted to try to reschedule a time and
day best to you and your family thanks
Rob I appreciate that I'm on the phone
at the moment but perhaps I just speak
to Eman first seems we have some time
and it's what you say I love it
especially later in the summer what
could we do if we do a call first thing
next week when I am back good morning
Emma just called and asked me to contact
you about something very interesting the
Crown prosecutor of Russia met with his
father Aris this morning and in their
meeting offered to provide the Trump
campaign with some official documents
and information that would incriminate
Hillary and our dealings with Russia and
would be very useful to your father this
is very obviously very high-level and
sensitive information but is part of
Russia and it's government support for
mr. Trump what do you think is the best
way to handle this information would you
be able to speak with Emma about it just
directly I can also send this info to
your father but it's ultra sensitive so
wanted to keep send it to you first so
you told me that you should tell that
point about Al Gore so okay this this to
me is is kind of mind-bending I have a
hard time even as like a staunch Trump
supporter that this wouldn't bend your
mind a little bit they you as a white
this time I Trump a trump supporter I
don't know what I said sorry I'm
defensive ugh you look like did you just
say English that this wouldn't bend your
mind a little bit you have a Russian
ambassador sending you incriminating
evidence stolen from Hillary's email
account trying to influence the campaign
on your behalf I'm not sure what are the
counter points to defending that because
I know as supporters do defend it they
say well who's troubled not to accept
help if somebody wants to help them
even if it happens to be an adversary
someone who it's best interests aren't
the United States so people would say
well Hillary's a a criminal and she
deserves to be outed or whatever it's
like an issue of morals right it's a
conflict of interest is what it is yeah
now to put it lightly lightly but but
the biggest problem here is that Trump
and his campaign and his son and
everyone involved has come as always
said with a absolute definitive way we
haven't had contact with the Russians
about any of this stuff yeah that is
crazy
so on one hand all these counter points
of Defense is like okay we could talk
about that but the thing that I'm
worried about is why have they denied
this relationship for so long and pretty
aware it if it was going to come out
eventually why why lie about it all the
time I don't know that they thought it
was going to come out eventually but but
you can see here even in this in this
short correspondence he says they sent
it to your father
and he says in the best interests of
your family which would imply that they
all knew about this from all of them
right so that the lines and the kind of
that what seems to be an attempt to
covering up this story a lot of people
saying why did he tweet this out because
it's like obviously incriminating people
laughing saying he's just dumb he's dumb
he would dump their idiots I don't I
don't think that's the case probably
most likely is that because the New York
Times was digging into this and they
probably figured that it was going to
come out and I think this was his if I
had to guess I would say he's trying to
get ahead of the story because it was
going to come out anyone you got you
want to you want to control the
information as much as possible you
don't want to give the control the New
York Times to me this is pretty much I
don't know it whether it would I don't
know the whole thing is just so crazy
it's it's spooky yeah I don't trust the
Russians to be meddling in our and our
governance and you should tell about
that point that you told me about Al
Gore
oh yeah and so okay again
look I'm not trying to trigger anyone
I'm Jen I know this is very contentious
to talk about this stuff but this is
pretty this is like the most smoking gun
on this issue this is pretty serious
stuff here now people are saying you
know here let me let me compare this to
something okay
back let me find this how do I not have
been info yeah but it's funny how it's
all about the emails I know this got a
[ __ ] ironic isn't it after all this
[ __ ] there's this email that's coming
back to haunt Trump jr. oh man you can't
write it better than this house of cards
has nothing on this [ __ ] it's like he
had YouTube with Twitter DMS and [ __ ]
opposed to their damn
they raised forever so just for
comparison now Al Gore
when he was running against Bush it was
back in 2008 if I recall correctly had
received information about Bush's debate
questions so he found out what questions
Bush was going to be asked during the
debate that gave him a hugely unfair
advantage because you could compare
he could prepare counter points they
could prepare zingers it gave him an
absolutely unfair advantage and the
first thing Al Gore did when receiving
those documents is he handed it over to
the FBI because it's the right thing to
do he says someone's trying to meddle in
our democracy there's an external force
at play here
who's trying to control the outcome of
our democratic process this belongs in
the hands of the FBI the CIA because I
think when you have external forces
trying to manipulate the outcome of
American democracy they need to be
challenged you know and and the thing
that's most disturbing to me about
what's happening with Trump and
supporters is their seemingly
willingness to be okay with the fact
that Russia aided
campaign and he he accepted the help and
he does and they don't see any problem
with that
mm-hmm the sway of public opinion and
everything I don't know about like voter
fraud I don't I don't I don't personally
believe or haven't seen evidence that
Russia like was hacking voting booths or
anything like that there was there's as
far as I could tell was clearly a war on
the hearts and minds of of the voters
but doesn't it I don't know it's it's
strange the fact that Russia had a
preference on candidate because Clinton
was notoriously very hard on Russia and
Putin in general she was a hard-ass and
Trump seems pretty [ __ ] soft he talks
[ __ ] on everybody everybody he's talk
[ __ ] on every world leader even people
in his own party know Marco Rubio
low-energy he shits on everybody somehow
Putin is this glorious horse riding [ __ ]
who has never done anything wrong who
has never assassinated political
opponents who didn't just make a war
mongering land-grab in Ukraine he's the
[ __ ] great like I'm just saying it's
it's concerning I think that everyone I
think that people should be concerned
about this that's my part I don't know
people saying next what do you guys know
well this is not a political show so I
don't want to get too much into detail
about things like that because I did
just give you anyway whatever that's my
thought I thought I find the whole thing
[ __ ] interesting let's move it on
let's get light now next story is a
great one that you guys are going to
love
anheuser-busch ex-ceo Augustus Isle
Duffus Busch the fourth subscribe
natural named Augustus Al Dolphus Bush
the fourth was arrested for flying his
helicopter while drunk his story is a
crack-up do them everything in this
story you gotta like read twice to make
sure you heard it right it's such a
great headline the former CEO of Ana
Hazzard Bush his name alone is unbeliev
augustus el dothis bush the fourth was
arrested after he landed his helicopter
and illinois' business parking lot
monday he landed his healthop there in a
parking lot I'm going to show you the
video swansea police said in a Facebook
post officers were dispatched to report
a helicopter landing for unknown reasons
around 1 o'clock in the afternoon and
we're concerned about the aircraft
taking off again due to closed obstacles
and buildings after 7 hours police said
they received a call saying the pilot
identified as Bush appeared to
intoxicated to take off the helicopters
rotors were spinning and the engine was
revving up when officer arrived on the
scene that is terrifying listen to this
[ __ ] Bush's wife DeWanna wood was with
him at the time in addition to their
eight dogs there was eight dogs in the
helicopter
that's a [ __ ] party dude but how do
you forget about drunk driving
let's drunk fly drunk not even for
helicopters you're more complicated
flying an airplane
let's drunk ass by a helicopter into
eight public partners in a neighborhood
you got to see the video ever it is so
funny
after a second officer arrived on the
scene the police administered eyes field
sobriety tests Bush appeared unable to
keep a single train of thought and his
speech appeared mumbling and slurred but
he blew a zero because because he was
[ __ ] up on pain gas Korea tells ishe
say it wasn't drunk but you exact which
is probably even worse he's like
knocking imagine nodding off in a
helicopter like nodding off in a car you
crash and you're probably fine you get
out yeah you're not often a health on
there it's your last news it's different
levels of adventure is that you can
crash into a house and I don't even know
don't be like hell yeah they're like
little family people so I hate flying
like by percentage flying is much safer
than driving but when you crash an
airplane
your your Brad buried can we get a
soundboard sound for that dent when you
crash an airplane you're I would sound
oh you are just waiting to see what he
chooses I didn't hear it oh we didn't
hear it did people oh thank you Dan
these into use real fast that's a great
story let's see here a further search of
the helicopter turned up several loaded
weapons weapons still and several
bottles of prescription drugs so this
[ __ ] gun is a helicopter with
eight dogs and much lighter weapons his
wife and and tons of pain pills watch
this for you
I can't let's point out no charges have
been filed in this case but here's a
look at where this chopper landed and
give you a sense of what's around here
this is just a parking lot in the middle
of an office park you've got a dumpster
a few feet away from where that
helicopter landed and you can see just
some of the other businesses I wonder
what he was doing there I wonder if he's
just picking up a Papa John's of some
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] did you need to
land your helicopter there no I think he
landed there because he felt unsafe but
he was about to get back and take off
yeah okay so that was an emergency
landing yeah oh maybe I'm too [ __ ] up
but I I don't know I'm not sure maybe I
hate called the cops right or not a
driver ya know one of the store
merchants called the police
oh my and they're like yo this drunk
idiots about to take off in his
helicopter and feels mankind I think he
dropped he stopped off for Papa John's I
need to talk to his wife she didn't
shoot a bear
she's chilling with the dogs and back
there having a great time it's probably
their favorite hobby my passions include
getting [ __ ] up on oxycontin and fly
my helicopter he wants a lift just say
quality time with our dogs dogs are all
freaking out of business here again this
is Ian Swansea a big office park here
witnesses tell us they wondered what the
world was happening when the helicopter
landed in the middle of this office park
now swansea police say the pilot told
them
he was visiting a business here now
according to my sources August push the
forwarding to my sources for the passage
on or large some crazy sticks could you
say them
it's just laughing at is there I mean
here and say no no no Fontana sources
August Bush the fourth was the pilot in
that chopper when it landed
now police investigate it because they
had concerns about how safe it was to
land in the area that rich people will
be doing whatever the [ __ ] they want I'm
gonna park in this parking lot by the
way no charges were filed what that's
what he said no charges have been filed
really all you gotta be is rich and you
can park your helicopter in some broke
people's house for all they care Wow
just we have the Commissioner a couple
hundred thousand that's a lot of my god
Bush that's with the Bush family that's
for me this guy's old money he's Bush
the fourth several hours later witnesses
anyone called
Algar that justice you know next person
you mean named Augustus you know his ass
got money he's got helicopter money
thanked it appeared the pilot was
intoxicated and trying to get back into
the helicopter and fly it out of here
sources say Bush the fourth was mumbling
and had trouble walking a court order
was sought for a blood and urine sample
he was taken to a hospital where those
samples were taken now the swampy police
chief says because no charges are filed
as of right now he's not confirming the
pilot was in fact August Bush the fourth
we're not confirming it was August Bush
the fourth but I've been one of the dogs
we don't know if it was one of the dog
driving we can't confirm his identity no
charges have been brought he he was he
appeared in the parking lot [ __ ] up
with a gun on him and pills on him we
can't confirm it he was him flying
though and so we're gonna let him off
the hook
get real all right next story that's a
pretty spicy one though I love his name
so much august's alphys Bush the fourth
it's actually just August it's got to be
a gusta s' yeah I'm gonna rewrite this
one August is not
not fascinating for me man tries to
murder a friend over argument of Star
Wars for Star Trek I love this this is
the kind of articles that live for
police fight over Star Wars and Star
Trek led to assault look at this [ __ ]
guy do you think this guy was onto the
side of Star Wars or Star Trek Jerome
white 23 was arrested July 1st in
Oklahoma City on a complaint of assault
and battery
serious business y'all police say a
fight over Star Trek and Star Wars led
to an assault Jerome Wyatt 23 was
arrested July 1st
on a complaint of assault and battery
Oklahoma City Police Department reports
show that Weiss had it thought like what
if they were arguing about something
else and then the police came and then
they're like trolling the police and
it's like oh we were just arguing about
Star Trek rule they're gonna cover it up
how do you confirm what they were
arguing about well okay so my that's a
really good point my thought is these
are probably not the brightest people I
don't know how oh yeah well if you were
arguing about drugs or something illegal
you would say we had an argument
yeah but if let's say if you were trying
to like stick it to someone or whatever
the phrase is by saying like something
really dumb that's what that's the kind
of thing you would say that's a [ __ ]
brilliant point kind of just ruined this
whole story well anyway the story is
Wyatt literally followed a man he says
here this is this is the from the police
report Oklahoma City Police Department
reports that white and another man were
in the living room apartment they shared
when they began arguing if star wars as
Star Trek was better the victim told
police he became frustrated and stated
you're just a trick before walking to
his room white allegedly followed the
man and shoved into the ground the
victim got back up and told police he
stated you want to replay that and
once again shoved to the ground police
say Wyatt then wrapped his arm around
the victim's neck and began choking him
the victim was near unconscious when he
pulled out a pocketknife
Wyatt let go and reached for the knife
cutting himself then left the room so
Dan pointed out and I think it's a good
it's a really good point they don't know
they don't say who supported Star Wars
and who supported Star Trek yeah that's
kind of [ __ ] important to resolving
this and my hunch on this is that the
guy who choked him had to be the star
wars fan because jean-luc Picard would
neither advocate in this kind of
behavior it's true you have to live by
the code of Star Trek so anyway I think
you killed that story from so if I'm
being honest I think these guys are
probably the greatest troll I think
they're trying to please but if you're
getting stabbed and choking each other
out
are you in the state of mind to be like
can't control the please what I just I
don't know I think you're on this make
sense in my mind yeah the police come
and they're like what was this argument
about and then the doors were Star Trek
yeah Yoda you know Yoda young all right
this is a short one but gave me a giggle
for sure White House misspells
inaccurately
in video accusing the CBO of inaccuracy
look at this [ __ ] the [ __ ] is this guy
okay here's the screenshot so they made
this really dramatic kind of like
where's that videos I have the source
video just the screenshot I guess I
don't they made this really dramatic I
didn't I don't know what this is about I
didn't know what the CBO is it's not
about that it was really dramatic kind
of propaganda video about the CBO and
then I said in accurately estimated 25
million would be covered under Obamacare
but they misspelled and accurately a
little bit of a meme a little bit of a
story it's a bit of a scoop was a bit of
a spoof a bit of a spaz as it were
moving on
that one didn't hit too hard a story
didn't hit too hard this is our first
time wearing how this goes
so you guys may have seen this picture
which is become a meme on the Internet
of itself this picture of Marco Rubio in
NASA let me see here hello is anybody
home this would well it will [ __ ]
internet you know at times you're out
what is this [ __ ] and this brings me to
the point of this video about net
neutrality throttling our interviewed so
here you can see you guys probably seen
this picture of Mike Pence the vice
president touching a thing on that and
NASA that says please do not touch and
he stared cuz with his hand on it
and so he tweeted out a week after
everyone was meeting on him he said
sorry NASA Marco Rubio dared me to do it
this is his actual this is his actual
Twitter account vice president pets
sorry NASA Marco Rubio dared me to do it
somebody's I this for campaign
this is this insane to you guys that
mark pants and Mark Mike Pence and Marco
Rubio walk around NASA touching [ __ ]
like a candy store some [ __ ] it's a
picture is amazing the fact that it says
right there not the types here it is
this is like a historic picture I like
this and a hundred years from now this
will be in history books critical space
flight hardware do not touch and sold
red letters and here's mike pence
without cracking a smile his hand for no
reason no purpose on this beautiful and
critical spaceflight hardware mike sorry
mark mark it's marcos fault he told he
dared me to i'm not sure like how old is
mike pence he's like 60 I'm not sure
even at the age of
fifteen I would be done here look at his
face he's so sincere oh man
so that's [ __ ] good right okay living
at home oh this is when Itoh found this
morning this is from Israel oh look at
this video yeah so you guys should enjoy
this woman destroys $200,000 worth of
art in pursuit of taking a selfie oh my
god excuse me oh Jesus how do I need to
read the article because the video
speaks for itself watch this [ __ ] it's
so brilliant this footage is incredible
watch the top right yeah the top right
you can see this lady she's about to
kneel down in front of it and they're
the dominoes oh okay so those were
sculptures I guess rare ancient
expensive sculptures and they toppled
over like a [ __ ] row of dominoes yeah
time of your thousand dollars yeah and
three of them were like permanently
damaged or something you stupid idiot
why would you leave first of all but
also the gallery yeah there's a pretty
shitty job here I take half the curator
and half her fault he'll glass no rope I
mean in this day and age you got to
expect that somebody's going to want to
Domino your selfie Domino to your ship
okay how are we doing so Dan did you end
up making that Shark Tank season four
intro [ __ ] yeah
okay moving on moving on to our next
topic I've been been watching binge
watching shark tank I'm obsessed with
that show we're both obsessed I can't
stop watching I don't know how many you
guys watch shark tank but it's like you
expect it to be really bad because it's
just it's a reality show and you know
all reality shows are pretty shitty it's
like force drama but this shows real as
a heart attack
if you guys don't know the premise they
have like all the super wealthy
billionaire cap investors and they have
people with real ideas come on the show
and they spend their real money
investing in these people and it's
fascinating it's riveting and Dan can
you play the soundbite and for those
reasons I'm out oh and for those reasons
and for those reasons you're out also
what happened to the accurate my sound
is a creative play that you have the
accurate my sours accurate it's like 15
minutes late we're going to play that
when they misspelled accurate but now
you guys know we have it do you have
anything like yeah blew it hmm can you
okay
anyway shark tanks and [ __ ] been
fascinating me and they always do this
thing well we're supposed to have the
soundboard though is that thing where
they go when they turn people down which
is like 90% of the time people come in
and they have like no business plan they
have no reason being there they've just
been a business that off any income and
they go for those reasons I'm out and
now I've been saying that about
everything in my life I'm like dealer
does that sandwich come with lettuce no
and for that reason I'm out and we're
supposed to have the sound bite but
here's what I was thinking because I'm
so obsessed with Shark Tank can you put
on that clip by the way damn I'm gonna
see it on Twitch how do i watch it oh
it's on the TV I'll just watch I have to
watch it on my own stream how can I
react to it well because if you want to
see it on the TV he has to switch to the
HMI cable yet oh I'm watching my own
stream to react alright look at these
[ __ ]
look at these goofballs man Damien they
get the black guy in the middle he
walked so funny his hands they'll move I
just am fascinated by the day I'll kind
of walk funny if you're focused on
they're so great like watch mark on the
left
he's got like a waddle
walks like a turkey or some [ __ ] but
Damien move your hands swing your arms
dog oh here yeah kevin o'leary mr.
wonderful this guy calls himself mr.
wonderful but he's such a character I
love him he always he comes out with the
most beautiful analogies to disc people
thinking I'll never forget he goes this
one about like the leopard seals who
jump in first indeed
this person came in without a business
planning he goes he goes every summer in
Alaska there's a group of leopard seals
that jump in the shark-infested waters
there's always one who's the hungries
who has to jump in first and most likely
he's going to get eaten but he saves all
the other seals should all the other
seals in this story that's you you came
into us unprepared and we ate you a lot
let this be a lesson to all the other
sea lions gone like damned this guy's
like Shakespeare and then also when he's
like not into someone he says and you're
dead to me and you're dead to me
oh you got to get that Dan we need that
okay you're dead to me he goes and
someone doesn't take one of his deals
you're dead to me
get out feel like we all need to like
watch an episode together just
straight-up watch it anyway so this is
what I was thinking
I love the show so much tell me why
think about this what someone says you
ran for office in Canada Kevin O'Leary
yeah oh my god I'm not sure I would vote
for him because he's like how is he
gonna be as a public service this is
very well be terrible all about the
money all I care about is money I'm not
sure I want that guy in public service
yeah they're like someone will come be
like I invented a new drug that cures
aids it cures aids but what about the
money we don't operate at our profit
all right we're all purely humanitarian
what about the money I'm out to me
you're dead to me I know no thing I want
to vote I love the guy not bogos anyway
trying to step the show up add some more
texture some more layers more segments
so here's what I'm thinking I want to
make my own version of the shark tank
I'm going to call it the fishbowl
we're all you guys out there with
business plans or existing businesses or
ideas can pitch your [ __ ] to us
we'll set up an email you send us the
details about your business your
business plan your revenue all this [ __ ]
and we'll evaluate it and we're going to
pick like the top ten to come on the
show and it's repeating segments called
the goldfish bowl yep
and the winner gets fifty thousand
dollar investment from us for I don't
know what equity we'll decide on the
equity well it depends on the page
that's yet all the hedge about the deal
the thing is I can't really afford more
money than that I don't have companies
I'm not a billionaire I can I can afford
fifty thousand investment I think I'm
hoping I'm planning on making my money
back from this genius whoever it is so
I'm just maxing out fifty because I
assume if I'm like I have fifty that
everyone's going to ask for fifty so the
prize is fifty mm-hmm here's the great
thing guys you get all the power all of
the support of the h3 nation we're going
to go slanting for you because we're
going to be business partners I'm
talking social media I'm talking YouTube
channels whatever you got we're in let's
make a lot of money together and for
that reason I'm in what do you guys
think what do you think that'd be a
[ __ ] great segment right I think it
could be like over a whole season of
this podcast or something yeah it would
have to be like ten a few months like a
reality show of like we get the pitches
we go over them we narrow it down to
like ten and then we've kind of narrowed
down to the top one that won't end up in
assyrians people watching live can also
help folks yeah we can even have votes
right so we're not set up yet but I want
to throw the idea to you guys sounds fun
start thinking about your pitches start
yeah I mean I'm looking for people with
existing businesses I'm not looking for
some guy who's like my idea is to make
an app that will show you where the
closest bathroom is
that's I'm sorry Phil it sounded a
really good idea to be honest so I think
next episode will start I'm going to set
up an email and I start getting your
guys's applications and then the next
episode after that we can start the
segment called fishbowl fishbowl $50,000
online that's a lot of money let's make
a lot of money together
that's exciting okay moving on
so here's another new segment we're
working on called what's trending on
YouTube and I mean I don't know if you
guys ever when you're on YouTube pop on
over to the trending tab but I've seen
some of the most godless unholy I don't
want going through religious theme
you've arrived
obscene garbage ever and it's always
this interesting thing of like why of
all the things to YouTube trend is
because when YouTube trends a video it's
very intentional it's neither it's never
accidental even though they want admit
it
it's got a very tensional it's a it's
not even debatable it's 100% a channel
and so I want to go every week and go on
the youtube trending tab and see what's
there and I've got one let's go there
and see what's on trending today I have
one video from over the week I want to
watch to go because it's just it was so
[ __ ] ridiculous my god let's see
let's see
this week on what's trending on YouTube
and you have the link I do but let's see
if there's anything interesting training
today
selfie Domino we just talked about that
it's all about the boxing but tell me
there's not something weird it's all
talk shows it's all promotional [ __ ] The
Daily Show it's all about this fight
music videos
I refuse to believe that this music
video French Montana's famous but the
studio the computer then is you know I
think it's showing you French Montana
ally has 300,000 views in seven hours
there's thousands of channels to do that
let's trend that why okay
Jimmy Kimmel 18 hours 300,000 views
you're telling me that there's not a
little foul play there I don't know
Kid Rock new music video 150,000 views
in 19 hours that's never been done
before but usually there's some really
words the vlogbrothers 70,000 views and
the thing is like there's always the
same channels like Natalie as a people
every time despite anything amount of
views time Mathias has been on there
every [ __ ] day the vlogbrothers are
there every day there's no way that he's
legitimately training with 70,000 Casey
and I said it's pretty much every week
pretty much every single video
Kasyapa lows goes to trending liza is
there every time all of a sudden there's
only five channels on youtube but where
is that warning video we want to talk
about yeah
very rarely where there's actually like
a legitimate like worthy video here like
here's one jenna Marbles she's on she
has 2.2 million views I believe that I
believe that our ending and that's
probably something someone would want to
watch but here let me show you one video
that caught my eye over the past week
that was on training and this is
probably one of the most obscene
examples of [ __ ] second one sec I got
open this document are you feeling you
tell me about yourself
wait are you going to be tell me about
yourself EULA um I think I had the news
segment is pretty cool
you like it yeah how do you guys like
the new segment so far as again I'm just
opening this document but after this
we'll take a break and then get into the
net neutrality stuff just in case people
are wondering I can open this [ __ ]
folder hold on one sec [ __ ] shared
with me okay here it is alright so this
one is called this video was called
parents explained masturbating to their
kids I think that was the exact Oh
parents explained masturbation
this was on the top trend I think it
topped out at number three on the
trending you can see here was number six
at a time of the screenshot
it's called parents explained
masturbation yeah and it doesn't have
that many views 300,000 views I checked
YouTube says trending is based on full
blog posts yeah like how much it's been
shared on other websites horseshit I
source the links on this video it's not
posted anywhere it's the same for any
any video on that trending page they're
not being shared anywhere on the
internet now it's ridiculous to claim
that so this video was on number two
trending at its highest point didn't
have that many of you has nothing
remarkable by any means but even beyond
it the video itself is pretty one of the
top columns was h2 issue should react to
this even beyond the fact that this
video is really kind of disturbing and
and not not that great is the fact that
YouTube made the conscious decision to
trend this and keep it up despite
everyone on YouTube losing their [ __ ]
mind like let me look at the comments
here they also say that trending is for
the purpose of discovery they think that
videos on trending are a good show oh I
got age-restricted well it's a little
[ __ ] late for that God okay
they finally age-restricted it was up
there for like five days it was everyone
who reported it so they finally I just
care like that's pretty fine though
because those kids in the video that's
that is that's YouTube doesn't make any
sense you a little bit of a conflict
there this is [ __ ] this video featuring
five year old is not you have to be at
least eighteen to watch it even though
it's about educating five-year-olds wow
that is pretty I can see that the moral
conflict they had I think that they
didn't necessarily need to
age-restricted
but the fact that they consciously put
this on trending and kept that there is
what disturbed me
um let's watch it I can't I can't hear
it then oh there you go or I guess I
should preface this by saying that I
don't I think that sex education is
important and I think that in the United
States is way too much shame and
embarrassment surrounding sex yeah I
agree with that
but those kids are pretty young I don't
know like they just shine them like sex
toys and I mean you should watch it I
don't know it's a weird it's a weird
visual thing that disturbed me is the
fact that they like filmed it for
entertainment because this is an
educational this is entertainment mm-hmm
right this is not what educational looks
like this is content for like adults
to be entertained by like Oh kids it's
just really I don't know it's really
embarrassing it just feels wrong
and I chose voyeuristic to me in a
really gross way snake today we are
going to be talking about masturbation
masturbation like this is a private
conversation you have with your kids
yeah you don't you should have filmed
this and show it to millions of people
humiliate very strange and you know the
producers are like mobile mobile more
vulgar mm-hmm more detailed talk about
tricking up yeah [ __ ] it Oh gracious
masturbation you kind of do it a lot
really but you know it masturbating is
when you touch your private in different
ways watch us get age-restricted know
you by talking about it make yourself
feel good is that right yeah that's a
good point we probably should not watch
should we just not that's how [ __ ] up
is Kel we really can get a district if
we're talking about this yeah we would I
want to watch it this is such a shame
but I think you're right
and smell so it's what I was getting
aids inflicted on the whole episode is
all conflicted about this right now
yeah right I think you're right it's
such a shame all right [ __ ] it
let's move on I'm so [ __ ] YouTube
everyone is like it's too late not too
late too late we did show thing we
didn't even show anything yet baby Jess
and II like dildos to 5y feels like
big-ass black [ __ ] yeah turns into like
an episode of black what is that
I took a four that were likes women
wouldn't little white girls but like
black dudes
I anyway I'm on the internet you know
anyways anyways good observe black this
video was great definitely check it out
on your own check it out where were we
so that's pretty much wraps it up for
our segments and news clips hope you
guys enjoyed that let me know what you
think because if I my plan is to
continue this at the beginning of every
episode say we had a guess they would
walk in at this point mm-hmm and then
we'd do that guest segment but this week
our main segment is about net neutrality
and we will get started on that but
first before that
[Music]
we have a flippin heck in AD Scott I was
reading the chat again I'm looking at
the Chester last hello hi Jen I cannot
look at the child so it's like so this
should you can't you just can't look at
it
I won't screaming like cut it I hate it
but I don't know if they're talking
about the video oh they were saying that
before and but the video cut the whole
thing so that we don't get a trick to
cut that part hope you guys enjoyed that
segment I also want to talk about
something almost forgot this game I'm
obsessed with this game player unknown
you're reading the chat you'll you guys
well here I talking to you and she's
like a wall she's not even acknowledging
that here we're doing that live show you
didn't even [ __ ] listen he's the only
person in this room alright loves it
letting everyone know I'm not what kind
of a chat your guys's fault all right
we'll look at it and during the breaks
and after yeah good I'm obsessed with
this game player unknown battleground
yep last night this game no it's it's
captivating it's one of the most
interesting of fun games I've played in
a long long time I've been playing
overwatch a lot and it's got so boring
for me and this was exactly what I was
looking for it's like you come in on an
airplane with a hundred people you
parachute into this big open space world
and it's a battle royale to see who's
the last one standing and you loot all
these houses it's super intense it's
really hard actually because you got to
be like it's real oh I need this gun
with this piece that goes with that gun
and then you need those bullets takes a
little bit of a rain man I'm not playing
by the way I'm just watching him he love
watches she's my military advisor my
last night we made it to numbers to
number two of a hundred and like I suck
so this was a huge thing for me like I
played beautifully and it came down that
I was in a little Hut and the thing is
the really really cool thing about this
game is that every let two minutes or so
the space and the map decreases and
there's this huge blue dome that
squeezes in on you and if you're caught
outside the dome as it squeezes in you
lose health
I didn't realize at the end that you
lose help faster mm-hmm so it's down I'm
in a little Hut and the blue dome is
close to almost like a pea size on the
on the sides of the map just me and this
other [ __ ] guy and I shotgun at [ __ ]
so I was blasting people in the face of
my shotty bite was insane Eva was like
fully turned on and so I'm in this room
and a little high and the other dudes
outside and the mini-map is getting
under the spheres getting so small that
I'm right on the cusp I thought I was
inside and I didn't realize it's gonna
die so fast but the blue orb closes in
and I just [ __ ] died in this room
yeah that's like this is not how this
game is supposed to end it's high octane
its high intensity
I just dropped dead in a room and the
other guy won I got second place is so
disappointing I think I would want if I
want to want to out there guns blazing
but it was cool do I recommend that game
a lot if you guys ever want to catch us
playing head on over to twitch where you
are now where you are now but on YouTube
you're not there push that TV slash a
straighter production we can watch the
podcast live every Friday and you can
catch us playing that game and doing
other stuff okay so before we go on a
break I want to thank our sponsors
they're the ones who make this possible
I love our sponsors man this whole thing
this whole studio this whole office Dan
out there with the switchboard can I get
a sound Dan
let me sunbright batteries I want to be
possible without the gracious support of
our sponsors so I'd like to say thank
you to first of all quit quit is
actually amazing product yeah they make
an electric toothbrush that's super
affordable and it works amazing it's
it's a we've been actually using it
since they sent us that one I'll be
using it every day for the past month
and like it's it's great it was named
Time magazine's best invention of 2016
it's really cool it's an electric
toothbrush you put it in your mouth as
you do toothbrushes
and it like basically tells you every 30
seconds it will stop vibrating for a
moment that's my favorite feature about
it it stops after three minutes right if
you're about to like pause before that
you know there's still keep trailing
dude yeah you disgusting monster keep
brushing not you but it's what it's
telling it's an amazing thing and it's
super it's like 25 bucks something I
actually don't know the exact price but
it's very affordable
it says here yet starts at 25 dollars
okay and it lasts and really lasts I'm
going to read their copy here's
something that you want I love reading
copy because I think you're something
that you on many recent studies suggest
that having good oral health impacts
your overall health yet most of us don't
brush our teeth properly I feel like
there's a better argument you have a
disgusting breath your breath is
discussing no one wants to stand next to
and smell you you're never going to get
data no one wants to kiss you
yeah okay it makes you healthy people
don't want to [ __ ] look at your
disgusting mouth
that's why you need quit introducing
quit the new company that's refreshing
the way people brush their teeth clip is
an electric toothbrush the packs premium
vibration and timer features into a
ultra slim design that's half the cost
of bulkier brushes this is my favorite
line it's basically like Apple designed
a toothbrush but without the big price
tag you have to see it and brush with
your so I don't know about that Apple
I'm gonna give they're saying it's sleek
its modern it looks cool I prefer if
they said it looks like well I am design
that would strike home with me a little
bit more well I had a new invention but
then it would not be functional
it would have weirdo just blow up in
your mouth you can subscribe to receive
new brush heads on a dentist recommended
three month plan for just five dollars
including free shipping right now my
friends you can head on over to quick
calm slash h3 to get your first refill
pack free with a quip electric
toothbrush
that's a faux read by the refill time
their link is not working did we crash
the website again oh no no quick calm
slash h3 did we seriously crash their
website I think we crashed some last
time too
that is strange
because we didn't get quit did you write
in the right you are an equipped comm /
h 3i i personally on a personal level i
recommend this product I've been using
it it's so hard to find like soft
bristles
I hate these hard bristles that you get
at the grocery store and I've always
been on a search find a soft one and
they have like a really wonderful rubber
kind of really soft texture and I I love
I've seriously been using everyday so
support the show if you're in the market
for new brush get quit by shot I think
you'll like a lot when their websites
back up when it probably would be back
up soon as well try to do a spot for you
guys huh all right next up quit Thank
You cliff for sponsoring our show next
up we have Dollar Shave Club you guys
know Dollar Shave Club they're one of
our oldest and best sponsors they've
been supporting us through thick and
thin and I just have so much love and
appreciation for these guys in the great
product they make Dollar Shave Club is
the smarter choice get a great shave at
a great price to beat and lead delivered
right to your door it's an awesome life
hack they wrote life hack it's not a
life hack this is a razor that delivered
don't you know it's adult product life a
life hack maybe what would a life hack
we take this pill and never get cancer
that's a life hack we have the we have
the Dollar Shave Club sugar yeah alright
it's a live hack and a no-brainer you no
longer have to schlep to the store to
buy cheap disposable razors that give
you a cheap shave or spend a fortune on
razors back with gimmicky shaving techni
you didn't aid so here's the deal for
limited time new members get their first
month of the exclusive razor and a tube
some reason to cracks me up you get a
tube of dr. Carver's shave butter for
only 5 bucks with Free Shipping that
includes your tube of butter shave
butter that is that helps you
not safe for human consumption I so
don't put that on the anyone thought
just being clear so you get a dang
freakin tube of butter shea butter for
cartridges and this beefy meaty very
excellent shaver now I use this anytime
I clean up my neck and my cheeks and
stuff because I've been to excellent
it's the only razor that doesn't give me
razor burn it's a really high quality
stuff I recommend a lot and it's super
convenient razors are so [ __ ]
expensive you ever go to the store they
have like a 8 pack like 50 bucks my dad
pointed out last time they put it behind
glass yeah I cut they do that they
freaking put it like high-end alcohol
behind glass and lock it so guys head on
over to dollarshaveclub.com slash h3 and
get your free exclusive razor for only
five dollars with Free Shipping cludes
for cartridges a beefy meaty razor and a
tube of butter
I recommend this product very much and I
appreciate them very much so if you want
to support the show and you're in the
market for Dreiser considered heading on
over to dollarshaveclub.com
/ HP and finally if you don't want any
of those products but you want to
support the show or you want it those
products and to support the show which
is an option i don't want to exclude
then you can head on over to represent
calm slash h3 they pick up your official
util Kleinert merge did we do this in
the beginning we did this trip in you
guys don't need more of that shook
mm-hmm
how we doing by the way I'm not shirt
I'm gonna how much we sold ready so it's
interesting on represent you can see how
many people bought 27 pouch doing
planner is it where the heel decline is
it alright alright I'm going to take a
quick break to run to the bathroom guys
hold on one sec didn't close to it oh
yeah I closed it in defiance of y'all so
we're going to just run to the bathroom
really quick and I'll be back in a short
minute to begin our discussion about net
neutrality if you go away
I just have a bad feeling I just have
bad feeling about it so please don't
leave welcome back everybody to the h3
podcast live so here we are to our main
story about net neutrality which has
been a hotly debated subject recently
and on Wednesday was net neutrality day
of awareness now my objective for doing
this piece I want to explain to the best
of my ability based on our research what
is it what's at stake who are the people
that benefit from it are there counter
arguments against it so let's let's
start from the top here what is net
neutrality which is essentially the
principle that Internet service
providers should enable access to all
content and applications regardless of
the source and without favoring or
blocking particular products or websites
and to break that down that essentially
just means a free and open Internet one
where the internet companies have one
job to give us the juice they don't say
what sites you can visit they don't say
what sites you can visit how fast they
just give you the juice and we and we do
what we want it's free and it's open
here's here's what people have said the
internet would look like without net
neutrality this is kind of like a
dystopian future of what it may look
like it's a lot like cable television
where I'll have to pay for HBO hmm yep
right for and the internet that that's
exactly right these big companies
Comcast Verizon AT&T t-mobile they are
trying to own the Internet they want to
own and control the Internet and this is
what it's going to look like eventually
you know it's like you have to include
Google Yahoo Flickr this is old you know
but YouTube Google Yahoo whatever you
have to pay $5 extra for this access to
the search engines or you have to pay $5
extra so that they
are quick enough that you can use yeah
then here's another one Hollywood
whatever entertainment YouTube Hulu
Netflix ESPN etc $10 extra like yeah sky
PayPal Amazon right now this [ __ ] is
illegal under FCC's rules but without
the principle of net neutrality which is
what everyone's fighting for this is
something that's very real and very
possible and some things that are
already happening today which is
something I want to get I want to get at
here so from the beginning the FCC
regulated the internet with their
general rules known as net neutrality
principle and they started getting
challenged from companies like Verizon
back in the 90s when the internet was
first created the FCC which is the what
does that stand for
I see Federal Communications Commission
they control all the utilities and [ __ ]
and they regulate it and they say what
you can't can't do essentially it's
there to protect consumers Americans who
consume these products so the very
beginning of the internet wouldn't be
started becoming widely used
they had this rule called neutrality
principles which in which the thing was
that it was a free and open Internet
that shouldn't be grabbed and controlled
by big companies like Verizon and
incidentally they started getting
challenged by companies like Verizon and
2014 a court ruled that FCC had no
authority to an up until 2014 FCC had
some control over this in 2014 Verizon
sued the FCC and a court ruled that they
had no authority to enforce network
neutrality rules because the internet
was not considered a title 2 utility
like telephones buses taxis etc which is
like a service that exists for the
public good yeah and so there's a lot
more restrictions or regulations on what
big companies can do with that service
so what is a title 2 so this whole
debate about net neutrality is
essentially trying to get the internet
classified as a title 2 utility
right now or previously it was a title
one utility which i think is like you
said cable mm-hmm it's not a public
utility really it's just entertainment
but the Internet is clearly much more
than that yeah at this point it's like
just life yeah like it's like the blood
of our economy of our society it's it's
more of a public utility that anything
that's ever existed you compare it to
telephone lines or sewage or anything
it's as much as that as as anything
that's ever existed and way more it
feels like pointless to even try to
explain why like like when I hate when
someone asks you to explain the meaning
of an piece of art right what you know
no you know you know the Internet is
like it's everything at this point and
it's so stupid to even have to try to
explain I agree it's it's the lifeblood
are as of our society and the world as
we know it it's even beyond it
so let me define for you guys what a
title 2 is and that's what this battle
is about ok so it shall be unlawful for
any common carrier to make unjust or
unreasonable discrimination and charges
practices classification regulations
facilities or services for or in
connection with like communication
services directly or indirectly by any
means or device or to make or give any
undue or unreasonable preference or
advantage to any particular person class
of persons or locality or to subject any
particular person class of persons or
locality to any due or unreasonable
prejudice or disadvantage that's what
being a title 2 is they're saying you
can't manipulate it you can't favor
anyone any service it's a public good it
is what it is it's free and open another
part of being a title - that's Part A
Part B is changes or services whenever
transferred - and this act include
charges for or services in connection
with the use of common carrier lines of
communications whether derived from wire
or radio facilities enchain broadcasting
or incidental to radio communications
see any carrier who knowingly violates
the provisions of this section shall
forfeit to the United States the sum of
$6,000 for each such offence and 300 for
each and every day of the continuance of
such offence so the FCC's like you have
to pay up if you [ __ ] around with this
[ __ ] now there's a debate of people who
say the internet shouldn't be regulated
because they believe that the free
market should be the controlling factor
and that company shouldn't be regulated
and they should be free to do what they
want that's a separate argument I'm
arguing but even before that the
internet is a title to utility if you're
going to say that the Internet shouldn't
be regulated and Verizon and Comcast
should be able to do whatever they want
then let's hand the sewage and the taxis
and the buses and the telephone lines
because they don't even come close in my
opinion that the internet doesn't in
terms of public good that argument is is
comes after the fact that it is a public
utility mmm-hmm I don't see any
reasonable way to debate that it's not
I really don't so [ __ ] Internet Pro
it's like yes it offers entertainment
such as cable but there's so much more
not the lifeblood of our society so
that's kind of what a title to us and
that's what this whole thing is about
trying to get the internet under a title
to utility now incidentally in 2015
other than President Obama and his head
of the SEC net neutrality was actually
granted to the internet it was a huge
victory for I remember when it happened
on reddit that they actually finally
after all debate and everything they
gave title to classification and DEMA
protected as utility they received 3.7
million comments and requests to change
the classification I remember when that
happened it was a huge victory and
everyone was excited now
[Music]
the FCC's new order established a
standard that required internet
providers to take no action that
unreasonably interfere or disadvantage
consumers or the companies who sites and
apps they're trying to access this was
deemed in 2015 when it became a title to
at most internet providers may slow down
services only for the purpose of
unreasonable or for the purpose of
reasonable network management I was the
only reason they could throttle Internet
services not a business purpose so now
this year Trump's appointed chairman PI
pay wants to ditch the title 2 and
return to the FCC's light touch title 1
approach and so title 1 is like what we
we're talking about that's just a
business yeah the thing is no so the
translation there is that that current
chair of the FCC wants to give the
control of the Internet back to the
companies and the thing is like people
say well you know if you go back before
it was fine and I think that
counter-argument to that is that before
2004 when Verizon sued the FCC and the
court said well you can't actually
regulate this because its title 1 which
is a fair ruling considering that is
true the FCC had more control over over
the Internet but there was this legal
precedent that took control away from
them and so the need for it to stay a
title 2 became greater so now they want
to go back to how it was except with
this legal precedent the companies can
run amok essentially gives them free
rein to do whatever they want with the
Internet the thing that blows my mind
about I just understand like why what is
it this Chairman what is his reason and
to give them that control Dan what were
you saying previously can you come in
here does that mic work
Tom I could work we would have to just
plug it in so this this Chairman Dan
what were you saying about this guy
this whole whole deal is he he he was
like the dissenting voice in the
previous administration so like when
Obama was doing the whole thing and he
was trying to what he call it
reclassified as title - yeah this guy
the current chairman he was on the
council and he was against it vehemently
because he I think it one I wanted to
write something right so he was that one
he was yes exactly and so as soon as the
new administration came in boom I gets
promoted he's now the commissioner and
of course immediately he does what he
said he always want to do which is keep
it the way it used to be correct so they
can just deregulate it right thank you
yep thanks Dan
this is brought to you by your Dan on
visual update so to try to answer your
question EULA the only thing I can think
of is like the conditions kind of
conservative economic vision of America
is like free market unregulated you let
the market figure itself and it's kind
of this this beautiful vision they have
of the free market yeah and I think it's
some cases that works but in the case of
companies like Verizon Comcast AT&T I
don't trust these [ __ ] people
I'm gonna get into that a lot later you
know so they're they already have so
much control like they've already made
it to the top what else is there to give
them what what do we what are they in
abling them to do what else is in yeah
they're they're already at the top
that's a good point and we've already
given them our trust and they [ __ ]
over the whole country which is
something an adding to a story that I
want to share later a reason why we
shouldn't trust these companies so the
thing that blows my mind about this is
the FCC is there it's a regulatory board
it's there to protect consumers a
rolling back the changes to net
neutrality would probably benefit 20
people to a thousand people I'm talking
about the CEOs of these telecom
companies and the shareholders literally
everybody else in the con
tree 300 million people stand to get
[ __ ] everybody else from the word
right yeah this stuff trickle down to
the the rest of the world these kind of
policies I just don't understand though
I mean it's like the impact of this will
be so negative to so many 99.9999% of
the people it just says the word that
anything that we even have to have this
conversation it's insane well there's
this great quote that out that I read in
context of this the price of freedom is
an eternal vigilance it's like you never
get to give up
this fights been going on for years it's
like every month
every year I see the same headline net
neutrality is under attack yeah and it's
like [ __ ] like not this [ __ ] again
you know us here in America in this
American democracy that we all take for
granted you forget that the price of
freedom is eternal vigilance mmm-hmm
we're all so [ __ ] lazy we're all so
take the ship for granted that when you
get lazy and you don't remember that you
have to fight for it every year forever
then all these [ __ ] these people they
they'll take it for you and you know and
you'll be happy about it it's like Mike
Tyson famously said I'm going to [ __ ]
you till you love me [ __ ] that's what
Comcast is essentially doing to us and
we love it and we love it they [ __ ] us
in the ass and now we love it
so and wonder what would happen to
people like us
Oh basically our whole living and
livelihood is related to the Internet
all right well the really like dystopian
nightmare vision and something that's
completely possible they can go so far
as throttling or disabling service or
access to a site to a channel to a
competitor and the thing is you don't
even have multiple carrier options if
you're in certain parts of the country
you only have access to 18 to you or you
only have access to comm cat so if
Comcast says all of a sudden I don't
like h3h3 productions
I don't want our users to be able to
visit them and you don't even have an
option you don't have an altar then you
don't get to watch HD reproductions and
there's no regulation right it's totally
totally in their power now I want to say
to the people who are sick who do say
the counter-argument that net neutrality
should be eliminated because it's just
another government regulation that an
unnecessary unnecessarily hinders
business and free market I want to give
you guys a glimpse into the future
without net neutrality by giving you
example of violations that have already
happened
here's a list starting in 2005 of
telecom companies violating net
neutrality and this is during a time
when it wasn't acceptable in the FCC was
able to sue them and take and challenge
them imagine how crazy it's going to get
when they have full rein so let me let
me start here 2005 Madison River North
Carolina ISP Madison river
communications blocked the voice over
Internet Protocol service Vonage bondage
is like Skype for your telephone okay my
parents lived in Mexico they got a local
California number from Vonage so you
could call them without incurring
international fees yeah bondage file to
complete with the FCC after receiving a
slew of customer complaints the FCC
stepped and Distinction Madison River
and prevent further blockage but it
lacks the authority to stop this kind of
abuse today so this is P was like this
Vantage of stealing business from us so
without saying anything to anyone we're
just going to block access so all the
sudden anyone with them can't [ __ ]
call they can't use this service
consists doesn't work doesn't work film
I mean this is some like North Korea
[ __ ] yeah in my opinion this is not
American comcast in 2005 the nation's
largest ISP Comcast began secretly
blocking peer-to-peer technologies that
its customers were using over its
network use users of services like
BitTorrent gee Nutella work
I don't know that one is theirs anyway
like BitTorrent were unable to contact
connect to these services 2007
investigations from The Associated Press
and the e FF and others confirmed that
conk Comcast was indeed blocking or
slowing file sharing applications
without disclosing this fact to its
users is such a nightmare so here you
are maybe ok maybe you're using
peer-to-peer technology for something
that's not illegal it's a pretty
wonderful thing it's amazing
peer-to-peer technology Comcast without
saying word blocks nobody or it just
slows it down slows it down to unusable
speeds which is almost more nefarious
yeah working but you don't know what's
wrong you're going to the settings
trying to figure it out and you're like
oh man this is America Comcast won't do
that no in 2005 Telus Canada's second
largest telecommunication company began
blocking access to a server that hosted
a website supporting a labor strike
against the company how about that
researchers at Harvard and the
University of Toronto found that this
action resulted in Talia's blocking an
additional 766 unrelated sites so here
you have a company directly suppressing
a political movement that wasn't alive
of their interests created
AT&T from 2007 to 2009 AT&T force Apple
to block Skype and other competing
videophone services on the iPhone the
wireless provider wanted to prevent
iPhone users from using any application
that would allow them to make calls on
such over-the-top voice services the
Google Voice app receives similar
treatment from carriers like AT&T when
it came on the scene in 2009 so imagine
you're on you're at home you're on your
wireless and you can't use FaceTime
because ATT forced Apple to block it
because it competes with their own
service it's just going backwards in
life like I just don't know why it's
such this romantic free-market ideal to
just lay
and let me [ __ ] you in that yeah it's
just not romantic to me I'm sorry
windstream in 2010
windstream communications a deal DSL
provided with more than 1 million
customers at a time copped to hijacking
user search queries made using the
Google toolbar within Firefox users who
believe they had set the browser to the
search engine of their choice were
redirected to win streams
own search portal and results yes it's
crazy so if you're using the Google
search engine this is P windstream
hijacked it to redirect that traffic and
inquiries to their own search engine I
can't believe that the this company did
this stuff when it was illegal too these
are the guys who got caught yeah soon
these rules won't even apply and they
can do all this [ __ ] that they want
Metro PC and 2001-2011 Metro PC at the
time one of the top 5 us carry wireless
carriers announced plans to block
streaming video over its 4G network from
all sources except YouTube Metro PC then
threw its weight behind Verizon's court
challenge against the FCC in 2010 open
Internet ruling hoping that rejection of
the agency's Authority would allow the
company to continue its anti consumer
practices so Metro PC says if you're on
our wireless carrier 4G that you pay for
the blocked all streaming video except
YouTube I mean YouTube how much so
essentially they're shaking down YouTube
they're blackmailing YouTube or
YouTube's compliant in this were they're
like hey I'll pay you 20 million dollars
and you block everyone else there's a
huge money-making scheme for companies
are already making money hand over fist
packs fire 2011 the electronic the EFS
found that several small ISPs were
redirecting search queries via the
vendor packs fire the ISPs identified an
initial Electronic Frontier Foundation
report include a caviar cognate frontier
fuse direct PC RCN and wide open west
packs fire would intercept a person's
search request at Bing and Yahoo and
redirected to another page by skipping
over the search services results the
participating ISP would collect referral
fees for delivering users to select
websites 18t and Sprint and Verizon from
2011 to 2013
ATT sprint resident blocks Google Wallet
a mobile payment system that competed
with a similar service called Debenhams
Isis I'm not showing you this the
competing service was called is is which
all three companies had a stake in
developing well you heard it here 18 t
sprint verizon started Isis somehow I'm
not surprised in Europe 2012 reports
from the body of the European regulatory
Oh for electric that's a mouthful
communications found the violation of
net neutrality affected at least one in
five users in Europe the report found
that blocked found that blocked or slow
connections to services like video you
know ideal apps peer-to-peer
technologies gaming applications emails
were commonplace Verizon in 2012 FCC
caught Verizon Wireless blocking people
from using tethering applications on
their phones Verizon had asked Google to
remove 11 free tethering applications
from the Android Marketplace these
applications allowed users to circumvent
Verizon's $20 tethering fee and turn
their smartphones into Wi-Fi hotspots
using their own Wi-Fi signal by the way
it seems like by blocking those
applications Verizon violated net
neutrality pledge it made to the FCC as
a condition of the 2008 airwaves auction
18 t in 2012 18 t announced that it
would disable the FaceTime video calling
app on its customers iPhone unless they
subscribe to a more
text-to-voice plan ATT had one goal in
mind
separating customers from more of their
money by blocking alternatives 18t
blocked disabled FaceTime on all their
customers phones Verizon during an oral
argument in 2013
Verizon verse FCC a judge asked whether
the phone giant would favor some
preferred services content or sites over
others if the court overruled the
agency's existing open Internet rules
Verizon's lawyer had this to say I'm
authorized to state for my client today
but for these rules we would have
already been exploring these types of
arrangements
Walker's admission may have gone on
notice that she had not repeated it
several times during the argument so
here they are basically saying if it
wasn't for the rules we would already be
exploring these options and I mean
they're already doing it regardless and
again what will the internet look like
without these FCC regulations Wells can
look like this here that's going to be
your menu on your telephone bill and
your cable bill your internet bill
mm-hmm and the United States already has
the most expensive internet almost on
the planet earth yeah there's no
competition if you put in Israel I was
shocked by the price there what was it
I'm sure we're paying like I mean if you
translate it to dogs I don't only $25
ain't I'm like five dollars a month for
like some really excellent internet then
yeah 25 a month I paying $100 now over I
don't think you can get good internet
for less than hundred dollars now and
also the cell phone company $5.00 a
month we're paying for a cell phone or
Japan $10 unbelievable I go I was
shocked by that you know so here this is
my favorite part of this story now once
again to counter the argument that we
should not be regulating these companies
they should be free to invest and do
whatever they want as the free market
dictates
here's a little story about these
telecom companies and what I think is
one of the greatest scandals in American
history
these are the guys that we want to trust
to deregulate okay let me read you this
[ __ ]
it's absolutely shocking it's it's it's
horrifying
so the broadband companies stole two
hundred billion dollars from the
American government back in the 90 or
back yeah back in the 90s during the
Clinton era they had this great vision
that the United States would be the
first broadband high access high
internet companies they wanted to
catapult the United States into the
future and give it the infrastructure to
be the technological touchstone what
happened because now the United States
has won the slowest internet speeds of
any developed country we're all last on
the list almost last on the list this
[ __ ] is horrifying so buckle up
basically yeah
in the 1990s clinton-gore era had an
aggressive plan to create the national
infrastructure initiatives to rewire all
of America with fiber optic wiring
replacing the hundred-year-old copper
wires the Bell company Verizon Bell
South quest claimed that they would step
up the plate and rewire home schools
libraries government agencies businesses
and hospitals if they receive financial
incentives to run the barrel to say this
because it's not showing no okay by 2006
eighty six million households should
have been wired with fiber the wiring
was going to be done in rich poor
neighborhoods in rural urban suburban
areas equally it was open to all
competition by 2006 by 2006 seventy-five
percent of the state of New Jersey was
supposed to be wired Pennsylvania was
supposed to have 50% of households wired
California five million Texas claimed
schools libraries hospitals virtually
all of the state the government in
exchange for building the networks
were given huge financial perks such as
tax cuts excessive prop not taxed on
excessive profits [ __ ] like that
so they estimate that on average the
amount of money the government gave
these telecom community companies to
build the fire offices somewhere in the
range of four to seven thousand dollars
per household we're talking about
hundreds of millions to five hundred
billion dollars were given to Verizon
Comcast AT&T to build fiber optics
throughout the country so what happened
dude
let me tell you basically what happened
is that they all promised the world and
none of them did it none of them did the
work so the country made people pay that
well it comes from taxes they make their
money so on average if you're thinking
about how the government spends its
taxes it was came out to four to seven
thousand dollars per household that's a
lot half a trillion and nothing ever
happened today they're starting to roll
out some fiber optics but the thing is
the government paid for this [ __ ] it's
supposed to be a public service yet if
you want fibers you still have to pay
out that ass for it
so for the most part even in 2017 we
still disclose Internet and it doesn't
exist no state has ever done an off and
audit on the monies collected by the
broadband companies no state every went
back and reduced the rates or held the
companies accountable no company ever
outed the other companies Verizon New
Jersey never said the eighteen T didn't
do it for example because they were all
in on
[Music]
these are the companies we want to
deregulate you you should look into that
stories it's it's horrifying
so I seriously one of the biggest
scandals in American history and I love
that vision of America as like the
technical center of the world mm-hmm
technologic we were going to be number
one before anyone else was installing
fiber optics we gave them half a
trillion bucks and they all said thanks
smell you later dumb-dumb so now to get
kind of back into the real world
situation and as we're saying the
internet prices is the highest they've
ever been pretty much the highest of any
country on earth so the thought of
increasing those prices in demand for
net neutrality is probably less likely
than what you're going to see from
t-mobile right now can you show this
picture down so t-mobile is already
doing this [ __ ] called binge on why is
it makings
I push control plus it makes it smaller
the [ __ ] is that about
okay so you guys may have heard of this
binge on they repainted at this
wonderful great thing for you
Vidia is now streaming free without
using your data cap only on t-mobile so
if you're watching videos on YouTube
Amazon HBO now Netflix fling Hulu ESPN
Fandango it doesn't affect your data cap
well what is the what are they selling
it is I don't understand it's just a
perk if you use t-mobile mmm-hmm
these don't affect your data cap but the
money is coming from somewhere it's a
shakedown of these big companies hmm you
know it's the that cost is being passed
on to these companies instead of you and
what it also does is it strangles out
it's funny they have this vision of like
deregulate the market but these
companies are preventing competition by
if you're not YouTube and you're making
a new YouTube create to better yeah you
don't have a [ __ ] chance because to
watch great
new tube your data plan which is already
[ __ ] to begin with yeah you're
getting you you end up paying more to
watch something else so all is it doing
is in granting the powers that be and
strangle holding any new competition but
it's confusing because I thought that
t-mobile had plans like we we have it
that that's one plan not everyone has
unlimited yeah not everyone has we're
all non limited but a lot of people are
on data you know and more compatible
data thing is oh yeah the data thing is
total is total [ __ ] does it cost
them more to bring you data is
ridiculous and cut more and more
companies are moving towards data caps
and internet providers who for the past
what 20 years have given you unlimited
internet are now moving towards data
caps and that's how this net neutrality
thing is going to take form through data
caps words like YouTube gets an
exception so just watch YouTube don't
think or watch or look at steam gets an
exception so don't try this other gaming
service that's coming up and better then
it gives YouTube and steam the power to
monopolize and [ __ ] you over yeah it's
just these old crony businesses and bed
together and trenching the
powers-that-be and making it impossible
for new competitors to come up it's
pretty horrifying and they the worst
part is they disguise it as this
wonderful thing binge on Brother Big
Brother they make it a sweet pill to
swallow
it's like point you know they say they
help to say poison is sweet split it met
a spoonful of sugar makes the medicine
go down right
but in terrifying reality that this is
what I'm saying
this [ __ ] is is it's tricky this net
neutrality [ __ ] is tricky it's
manipulative it's a dirty we're talking
about Comcast the every year voted the
most hated company on earth you search
Comcast on Google Images an Aussie a
Nazi swastika comes up
I'm not kidding by the way let me do
that they've been meme Don so hard okay
my point is do you trust these companies
where's that supposed to get Oh Google
isn't bad the people do this every day
on you okay yeah Google Google's in bed
with Comcast they remove that [ __ ] my
point is do you trust these companies do
you me I would never have they given you
any reason to trust them to deregulate
them are they the ones who stole half a
trillion dollars from the government are
they the ones who are already violating
net neutrality who are already having
this big job brother 18 T came out on
the day of action to support net
neutrality that can you believe that 18
t we support net neutrality of course
the irony not lost on us since AT&T
which in 2012 blocked customer access to
Apple's FaceTime let's say subscribe to
a more excessive plan
AT&T who spends millions of dollars
lobbying to reverse the FCC's
reclassification of broadband providers
as common carriers under title to the
very same protests that they are
participating in to prevent fact ATT
already sued the FCC in 2015 over this
and lost but of course ATT supports net
neutrality to confuse the issue these
[ __ ] are tricky on such a joke that
they would say that they're disgusting
they just they pray to the almighty
dollar and it's what I'm saying it's
tricky it's confusing their manipulative
with this binge on think good 18t
supports net neutrality for me it's it's
I don't know it's kind of like it became
like a trendy thing for the big
companies to say that they support it
yeah into the layman who just like it's
a buzzword net neutrality right to the
person is just sitting at home watching
the local news watching the
daily news and they hear this bug Ford
they don't really understand it they're
like oh AT&T sports it binge on you know
don't regulate the internet what do i
what do I know
who cares the internet was created and
funded by the governments and scientism
very beginning as a public utility was
never meant to be owned by companies
like Comcast AT&T t-mobile and Verizon
people will never have the the best
interest of people never so to that I
just say the price of freedom is eternal
vigilance and just by talking about it I
think we raise awareness just by
educating people and sharing in this
experience of saying like this is [ __ ] I
acknowledge that this is just a huge
money grab that will benefit a thousand
people at the expense of 300 million or
more and it and like it this is just
this whole beginning of this this whole
divide of like the super wealthy and
normal people this is the beginning if
you hand over net if you get rid of net
neutrality the Internet is our is our
only source of organizing communicating
participating in democracy this is the
lifeblood of our modern society we
forfeit that to these companies also
you're going to leave everything in the
hands of this big companies to decide
what is what like how are they even
going to decide what goes in which plan
you know what I mean like does ready go
and a Facebook kind of right a branded
they are going to charge this much far
does it go with Wikipedia and they're
going to charge this much for it because
Milan was a Christian like just to make
you pay more it's like who is going to
be making this decisions people will
probably have no idea what they're
talking about
of course it's like a real dystopian
future I mean this is the beginning of
some really horrible slippery slope so I
say share the awareness let these
politicians out there know who are who
are you know speaking and voting in
support of getting rid of net neutrality
that
if they do they forfeit their jobs let
them know that your you don't agree with
that if you go to a website battle for
the Netcom which I'll put in the
description and here in the chat right
now then you can easily fill out a form
on this page with your name email
address zip code telephone number and a
letter to the FCC in your government
body to Congress saying that you don't
support it and have your voice be heard
so that's pretty much it that's pretty
much all I have to say about that now
just by understanding the issue and
knowing what it means and knowing what
your opinion about it is it already
helps you know because the worst is when
people vote on something they have no
idea what it actually means like a lot
of people were saying would brexit
Google voted and only afterwards
realized what they voted for I think in
this day and age when there's something
at stake or something to the vote that
disadvantages the majority of people who
would vote on it it's this war of
information of confusion that's the only
way stuff like this wins because if
people understood what it was it would
never never pass so they spend millions
of dollars on campaigns and influencing
information why they own like why Rupert
Murdoch of all people owns like almost
every telecom company I don't know I'm
telling you this is important guys so if
you're if you're in the comments I'm
curious I haven't heard a really
persuasive counter-argument and I wonder
if there is one if you happen to have
one or you think that you have an
interesting counter-argument I'd love to
hear it in the comments but anyway guys
not the most funny or or [ __ ]
light-hearted one but I thought it would
suit it was suiting considering the
situation we're in we made a video about
it previously on h2 h3 and I really
think it's important more more important
important than then most people
understand
see what I'm saying call Joe in the chat
do you want to call him to it and now to
finish off this podcast I saw Julie do
don't give a [ __ ] about net neutrality
let me just call Julie this is the last
episode and being serious on nobody
cares they just want here Joey salads no
no they will care Julie on the phone
hopefully is taking a dump like last
time Oh Joey you're live okay oh yeah
how you doing caught me off guard
I always good just assume every time I
call you it's on the it's live oh yeah I
was jerk oh my god I was saying I hope
you're taking a [ __ ] would you usually
answer the phone when you're jerking off
when your friends call you only when I
call you like this and it accidentally
cause the the answer bothers what are
you watching I'm just trying to [ __ ] my
daughter what you're trying to [ __ ] your
phone I'm trying to park my car oh
you're not wrong
that's what scientists started so I'm
just curious ago Canada I'm just curious
if there's any Soflo updates um you
shared another video okay tell me how
big you put me in like a group with his
goon and you going to sharing me oh you
got the girl we asked for not the goon
shares though we said four leglock
shares but it was at a good time but
there was like his girl like you did
pasta sharing so it wasn't on the so
flow page
no it's is sharing people source about
you like don't want to work for them and
then they shared me on Proform okay good
excellent so your so just to keep the
count you're at two legit shares and one
nighttime share yeah so it might be any
solos you one-and-a-half more shares
yeah okay we're going to keep we're
going to follow this closely make sure
or my name isn't oak Francis the third
all right jelly well I hope you're doing
well yeah thank you keep it up on things
I wish you the very best what do you
what are your opinions on net neutrality
I'm I don't even know anything about it
okay
that's right a quick left down there
I'll tell you my opinion um we just
talked about it for like an hour and a
half no yeah I'm not sure if people are
ready to rehash that but you know what
would one mistake like this I was I
would want it to be the most the most
free version of the Internet where less
government control whatever whatever
option that would be like router
situation so that's the complicated
matter is where it's like free and
government control almost contradict
each other in this case because without
the government control the big companies
are making it less free hmm all right
the companies have control in the
government really really yeah so this is
subtle trust and girl were lucky
wow that's it so even if the company
organic things work so so this is what's
happening tell me what you think the
government is saying they're passing a
law net neutrality which means nobody
can regulate it they says the company
they make it illegal for the companies
to control the internet that's the whole
purpose of the regulation Wow
that's what I mean like a government
government bill essentially they're
they're saying the Internet is free is
open and nobody can control it then on
the other hand the telecommunication
companies are saying I don't want you to
regulate it because I want to control it
so let me give me I got the research on
this before I got that's very
complicated I do research I love to I'd
love to talk with you about it because
you seem like someone who would who
would be against net neutrality and I
think this would be a really fruitful
conversation yeah definitely ah I'm
going to research a little bit I mean I
don't know how long you're going to be
live for if you want to talk about it
that's not okay I'm gonna call you up
next week I love this this weekly Joey
so update with the MELD man weekly salad
yeah the weaker dog
how good all right so do some homework
I'm let's talk about it next week all
right cool all right that sounds great I
wish you the very best my friend and I
wish you a very very Ranchi evening
thank you alright peace did well but but
love that guy love the salad man this is
where dreams are born man you start
beaming on a guy you call him a solid
head and [ __ ] and now you're best
friends that's the end of the po po law
what was it Poe's law that's like it's a
continuation of where we started this
episode full circle all right I guess
that's about it that boring nobody cares
good we just want to laugh sometimes I
got to get serious though it is
important I think it's important to me
but that's the way the cookie crumbles
my friends so with that I wish you all
the very best we'll do a little
after-show so don't go away but for the
purpose of the podcast I say thank you
all so much for watching thanks for
watching and next week we'll be back
with Jack films and Eric from common
etiquette and the week after that you
will not want to miss because we have
Rudy pantalla jr. aka humongous joining
us
we're flying him out from Seattle and
we're putting them up and I'm super
excited I mean talk about VIP guests
okay that's incredible we're going to
meet them demand to myth the legend
himself so thank you guys all for
watching and we shall see you next week
goodbye peace